von hier ist es nicht mehr weit bis in
die Ukraine
wir sind auf Patrouille mit der
moldauischen Grenzpolizei
es ist eine kleine Einheit von fünf
Männern und Frauen die wir begleiten
einer von ihnen ist Boris nitschan 12
Stunden am Tag behält er die Grenze
genau im Blick seit Kriegsbeginn keine
leichte Aufgabe
ich spüre wegen des Krieg so eine Unruhe
in meiner Seele wir alle wollen dass der
Krieg so bald wie möglich beendet wird
und vor allem dass er nicht auf unser
Land übergreift
Angst vor dem Krieg und dass er
irgendwann auch nach Moldau kommt er
wohnt nicht weit entfernt von hier mit
seiner Frau und seinen zwei Kindern sein
größter Wunsch ist es dass seine Truppe
und er diese Grenze irgendwann nicht
mehr so schwer bewachen müssen dann wenn
die Ukraine und Moldau beide Mitglied in
der EU sind
ich hoffe es nicht nur ich glaube fest
daran dass die Republik Moldau der
Europäischen Union beitreten wird es
wird eine Union sein ohne Grenzen die
uns behindern
die Republik Moldau liegt zwischen
Rumänien und der Ukraine zwischen Krieg
und Frieden die autonome Region
transnistrin im Nordosten des Landes hat
sich vor 30 Jahren einseitig abgespalten
ist zu 2000 russische Soldaten bewachen
dort ein riesiges Waffendepot
pro Europa oder prorusland die Republik
Moldau ist in dieser Frage gespalten und
so ist die Stimmung auch in der
Hauptstadt Chisinau angespannt seit
Wochen gibt es immer wieder
Demonstrationen
sie demonstrieren gegen die Präsidentin
Maja Sando und den Pro europäischen Kurs
des Landes organisiert werden diese
Proteste von der Pro russischen
Opposition die aus ihrer Haltung keinen
Hehl macht
wir sollten hervorragende Beziehungen zu
Russland haben da Russland schon immer
unser strategischer Partner war
seit Wochen gibt es Warnungen vor
russischen umsturzplänen es steht viel
auf dem Spiel eine Moskau freundliche
Regierung in Moldau könnte die Ukraine
auch von Westen her bedrohen Moldau ist
abhängig von russischem Gas Moskau nutzt
das aus und erhöht immer wieder nach
Belieben die Gaspreise das Ziel die
Stabilisierung viele können das Gas
nicht mehr bezahlen und so wächst den
Moldau die Unzufriedenheit
besonders betroffen von den russischen
Energie Schikanen ist die arme
Landbevölkerung wir sind in kirtrrosso
20 km außerhalb der Hauptstadt die
Temperaturen liegen knapp über null Grad
die Winter in Moldau können kalt werden
wie heizen wenn das Gas kaum mehr
bezahlbar ist Bürgermeister leoniewski
musste sich etwas einfallen lassen und
hat Holzlieferungen organisiert denn
Holz ist viel billiger als Gast
die Lieferung ist Chefsache auch beim
Ausladen packt der Bürgermeister selbst
mit an doch das Holz reicht längst nicht
für alle
wir haben insgesamt Anfragen von 600
Familien für Feuerholz erhalten
mit der Hilfe aller Leute hier in der
Gemeindeverwaltung von kirtrosso haben
wir es jetzt geschafft Brennholz an 150
Familien zu liefern
die nächste Lieferung bringt leoniewski
zu galinas Gallus sie ist 70 Jahre alt
und hätte nicht gedacht dass sie in
ihrem Leben noch einmal Brennholz
schleppen muss das Dorf wurde eigentlich
vor über 10 Jahren ans Gasnetz
angeschlossen seit diesem Winter muss
sie doch wieder mit Holz heizen
etwa aus wie das 21 Jahrhundert im
Zentrum von Europa
wer ist schuld daran
das System ist schuld
das System ist für Galina die
pro-europäische Regierung und die
Präsidentin Maja Sando
und die werden gesteuert vom Westen der
NATO und den USA sagt Galina in Ihrem
Wohnzimmer läuft russisches
Staatsfernsehen in Dauerschleife sie ist
der Meinung dass Russland keine Schuld
am Krieg in der Ukraine habe
ich denke es gibt niemanden außer
selensky der diesen Krieg so sehr möchte
er möchte dass dieser Krieg sehr sehr
lange dauert das sagen sie in Europa und
selbst beiden hat das gesagt Lang Lang
Lang
die russische Propaganda wirkt auch auf
dem Land und facht die Wut der Menschen
an doch der Staat hat mittlerweile
reagiert und zahlt die Hälfte der
Gasrechnungen die EU unterstützt Moldau
finanziell viele Menschen sehen das und
so sind hier in kirtrosso ca 50% der
Einwohner für einen schnellen Beitritt
zur EU sowie Bürgermeister Leonie
saljewski
ich hoffe dass jetzt alles besser wird
wir können nicht noch mehr ertragen das
alles ist das Ergebnis von
Wirtschaftskrise und krieg die Krise
in Moldau prallen Russland und der
Westen aufeinander das kleine Land ist
Schauplatz eines geopolitischen
Machtspiels gewinnt Moskau hier die
Oberhand hätte das Auswirkungen auf die
ganze Region
[Musik]